Glencore came out just about an hour ago
and made us feel a little bit better
because we've all been scratching our
heads trying to figure out why this has
been going on with the share price today
Glencore saying they have no idea why
there's been such a fluctuation in the
share price I will tell you one thing
over the weekend the Telegraph had a
story out saying that mr. Glasenberg who
happens to be CEO of the company known
about eight and a half percent of its
shares was open to a takeover offer
though and this is an important though
he said there's nobody out there that
would buy the company for fair value the
message should be we are fine the banks
of supporting us and we are going to
continue doing what we have prophecies
they leave it at 10 billion dollar
reduction in debt for that we already
raised two and a half billion in equity
we canceled the dividend and now the
priorities bring the extreme gold deal
that we understand is quiet Vance it
could be between one and one and a half
billion dollars are more importantly
deliver and bring some clarity on what
the plans for agriculture and as son of
the investment banks and our own
reporting on Friday is indicating tiles
tolls are underway and the whole
business could be value as much as 10
billions on us
we've had research reports in the last
few weeks as you know saying that
current commodity prices Glencore isn't
viable I can't comment on on whether
that's right or not but when you're in
that kind of environment you've got a
lot of volatility because going busts
are not going busts are very different
things you can trade out of lots of
difficult situations but if you can't
trade out that's it game over